peu
[Musique]
à
alors je dis qu'à de vison
de renard et un castor et un castor
hélas un vision qu une heure une
marmotte un loup un je suis là comment
tu le sais
et longtemps qu'un nouveau chez lavigne
quinze jours reste à apprendre apprendre
quoi
ghoga
c'est plus
ça fait au moins la cinquième fois que
la ville d envoi de la drôme
et je parle pas de celles qui parcourent
madrid est celle qui s'en vont à cologne
à temps
[Musique]
tk garder ce bout là au prochain envoi
du vérifiera toi-même long lavigne
fourrure pour l'italie ces prêts les
papiers vous dites en chef
[Musique]
le discours du camp
bref on s'y fait mieux
[Musique]
stein
jaloux un châssis
tu vois tout de même pas trop bien
s'envoler deezer n'est pas loin de 5 50
j'attends donc foulon j'attends la fin
de cette guerre
tu crois pas c'est sa rose et tout
pareil un fort succès intéresse
[Musique]
ouais en six heures chemin d'avenir
la prescription le temps d'un milieu à
part le petit gars qui va débarquer à
orly impeccable netflix juge n'a pas été
si mal que ça
[Musique]
mec super g
aurait-on
j'ai vraiment la vigne
elle demandait ma part tous et pour
l'histoire les fours
ça fait quand même car en briques c'est
un partenaire parfaitement correcte en
affaires
[Musique]
ce fonds
vianney bilici
l'aja tient là
mais camalès taiwan taiwan
[Musique]
et et qu'elle avait volé pression' ai
dit au revoir ses dents avaient promis
que les mieux que tu n'attends pas jeudi
puisque j'ai qui arrivent pour la
prochaine livraison de projets attendre
une minute de plus non
je la rejoins je prends ma part et
bonsoir
[Musique]
aussi avant
jouent ils reviendront à
cinq ans et ne brûle que patron les
joueurs c'est bien qu'à paris pour ne
pas que tu parles
les autres ont déjà essayé de tes
dessins
pourquoi je trouve
les flics un peu plus moyen terme c'est
fini
bon gérant regardez cette photo prise à
rome par interpol rhodia louis 36 ans
fausses factures délits divers chèques
sans provision condamné par contumace en
fuite depuis cinq ans le seul maillon
qui nous a manqué dans la sphère des
métaux non ferreux
malheureusement la prescription pompe
aujourd'hui à midi il nous faut donc
l'audition d'un témoin bravo gironde
pourquoi audition d'un tiers au sujet
d'une affaire en cours
acte interruptif de prescription délais
de clôture portées à 3 ans bravo jérôme
à vous allez donc prendre un gardien
avec vous est allé me chercher
le témoin qu'elle témoigne c'est le juge
treport lequel vous montrerez ah ben oui
c'est un petit artifice de procédure
mais ça m'offre le temps de reprendre la
faire aller à cheval jeunes
[Musique]
ah non c'est pas moi qui aime les yeux
c'est l'autre moi j'aime que le bacon a
comme c'est intéressant et bien voyez
vous mon cher ami nous avons exactement
les mêmes goûts alors je vais pour la
forme ou faire lecture de vos missions
nouvelles terres de but francis
d'instruction délégué je vais garder sur
ce il y avait recueilli ce jour la
déposition du nommé mercadier joseph
ange justin théophile c'est bien ça né à
issoudun le 4 janvier 1932 de pellegrin
n'exerçant actuellement aucune
profession demeurant qu'avis être qui
nous a déclaré ce qui suit je vis des
subsides
le web a milité depuis deux ans offrant
un contenu des saveurs confort là
enfin voilà ce que je dis fait à paris
le temps voilà vous mettez six combats
votre signature
et tout sera parfait
je vois pas dans merde sur sûr pas
d'emmerdés
on adjoint va vous remettre la somme de
20 francs
on va mal deux mille balles
voilà merci puis je me permettre de vous
filer une si mich
vous n'aurez pas le temps mais selon
jérôme va vous faire reconduire par une
de nos limousines au domicile de votre
choix
malema le ciel monsieur au revoir oui
mais chez moi oui
oui ah bon
mais bon je vais me laisser ses
répliques
la britannique
[Musique]
c'est à 6,6 et non ferreux
oui vous savez je n'aime pas abandonner
une question d'équité mais où diane et
plus en france et puis ce n'était qu'un
comparse pourquoi vous attaquez lui par
ce qu'interpol vient de me prévenir
qu'il a l'intention de rentrer et à
partir de ce moment-là il m'intéresse
parce que grâce à lui on peut remonter
toute la filière 1 et la filière c'est
merci madame de veille ou voilà madame
de veille aux femmes du monde
enfin connaît tout paris veuve d'un haut
fonctionnaire et dans la sphère des non
ferreux elle a bénéficié d'un non lieu
bien entendu c'est une bonne combine
je me souviens surtout que je n'avais
pas compris grand chose à cette affaire
comme d'habitude d'ailleurs dans ce
genre d'histoire j'ai cru remarquer que
vous auriez beaucoup de difficultés à
vous faire muter à la brigade financière
oui à moins d'un gros piston d'une
catégorie alors je vous résume en deux
mots voilà on expédie fictivement en
allemagne des péniches chargé de lingots
de métaux non ferreux
mais on établit une vraie comptabilité
les péniches ne bouge pas mais les
factures elles circulent moralité l'état
rembourse 25 % de tva dans cette affaire
ça faisait à peu près 800 millions de
francs
léger léger et c'est cette petite dame
qui a acquis et tout ça dans la tête
oui mais malheureusement je n'ai jamais
pu le prouver
et vous pensez y parvenir maintenant
mais parce que maintenant je suis tout
seul vous êtes là ah ben oui chef et
puis parce qu'à l'époque j'avais
sûrement fait une erreur
madame devrions n'est pas tout seul il
ya quelqu'un derrière elle quelqu'un de
très puissant et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'elle s'en est sorti mais
qu'il a porté un grand patron est très
grand j'en ai cinq ou six dans le
collimateur mais un particulièrement je
le connais oui comme tout le monde mais
si je vous dis son nom vous allez tout
de suite demandé votre mutation pour
carcassonne et vous aurez raison
on peut avoir des en mer de monde
partout ménard kasraoui mais là les
emmerdements bon risque d'avoir très
copieux parce que plus on vise haut
et plus les retombées enfin espérons qu
exceptionnellement la tartine de
confiture retombera du bon côté
[Musique]
on était habitée ou à paris chez moi
regarder mon appartement 5 ans pour rien
c ou votre appartement
c'est là c'est marqué 24 rue pierre
demoures moins que les changements
[Musique]
oui allô principales villes qui oui ici
policière est encore hors livres oui je
vous signale que dia louis en fuite
depuis cinq ans vie de recherche 167,50
3 vient de débarquer en provenance de
rome 24 bien de vous bonjour merci à guy
millière ah oui de bien jouer sur la
fraîcheur de moore henry
24 rue pierre demoures
quand france mon portugaise
faut que je sois là
[Musique]
dans l'intimité les fenêtres a
millionaire l'envoyer sous douane ils
dédouanera demain le camion pour la
hollande est prévu pour samedi prochain
marchandises sont de retour dimanche
soir et a plus qu'à faire les comptes et
andré ça fait 60 mois que j'ai part de
la france dans tu crois pas qu on pourra
attendre trois minutes avant de parler
boulot
ok vous dit est arrivé de rome il ya une
demi heure
or l'idée de me signaler à un
commissaire jarty et bien c'est parfait
vous savez où le joindre
vraisemblablement chez lui bien celui là
bien alors vous y allez vous priez ce
garçon de bien vouloir passer à mon
bureau à 6h motifs simples auditions et
s'il refuse arrestation d'accord merci
voilà
[Musique]
et
à
[Musique]
c'est bien et heureux ce gentil le cev
occupé de tout y'a même des fleurs
or j'ai l'impression d'avoir quitté cet
abonnement hier soir merci andré merci
de le regarder dans les temps
pourrais-tu me disent qu'on est une loi
pour les 50 de questions on verra ça
plus tard où on en est on en a le coin
les comptes et biens avec les avances
que tu as eue à rome sa doivent faire un
peu plus de quarante briques je te
donnerai le détail exact
non ça correspondait calcul jeu pour les
touches et comment
dès que j'aurai fait du liquide mais
quand tu veux louer à partir de demain
quand tu veux
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est holy s'ouvrait je ne
sais pas voilà j'arrive
monsieur indien oui comme ici à
villequier
am
ah bah je vois quand tu perds pas de
temps déjà une petite réception c'est
pas terrible en pareil tu lis
l'accueillante surtout pour le retour
les enfants prodigues bien sûr c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis né vous
accueillir mais alors dites moi mon
passeport les parents règlent j'ai pris
un mauvais avions jets privés au tour
eiffel au non pas du tout non non vous
n'êtes pas je suis venu vous portez une
communication du juge albert albert ii
n'avait une chef du syli et si ali
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc le syli
a le service interministériel de liaison
et d'information avec pour entendre
votre témoignage dans la sphère de
métaux non ferreux vous souvenez la
petite escroquerie à la tva les 6
milliards
vous croyez pas que vous vous remontez
au déluge commissaires non car le but
aujourd'hui midi est d'environ 14 heures
il ya prescription hé bé oui mais plus
rien contre moi erreur monsieur des
rires oui car le juge van der vient
d'établir un procès verbal d'audition de
témoins acte interruptif de prescription
vous en prenez si j'ose dire pour trois
ans à être sur la sellette
d'ailleurs voici la convocation alors je
vous prierais d'être à 18 heures au
cabinet du juge yves albert ii 9 et le
ministère de la justice 6e étage porte
675 si je n'y vais pas s'il n'y avait
pas alors j'ai pour instruction de vous
arrêter
je serai au rendez-vous à 6 heures
cliquez sur
mais qu'est ce qui se passe ces [ __ ]
et contrôler dehors les ont prévenus la
pj l'heure fatale des contrôles
commencent toutes façons 2 sec de la
routine
poutine ou pas tant que la dernière
votation pour rome n'est pas terminé on
a intérêt à prête souvent ensemble moi
qui pensais que tu montres escale neuf
dans paris ce soir la porte et
cigarettes déscotcher tes copines je
téléphonerai demain je t'apporterai tu
as peur je sors le premier toit dans 10
minutes à ce soir victor se voit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
madame de vulliod s'il vous plaît tant
dans la vigne mais bonjour c'est un
vestige lui odiah commande rentre à
paris lé van damme et conseils et chez
lui depuis souffert
ces faits convoqués par le juge pour
audition dans la sphère de nos forêts la
prescription djoko c'est un commissaire
qui s'est dérangé lui-même pour lui
apporter la cooptation
l'embêtant c'est vicky et je crois
civile s il est même devenu l appareil
pourrais-je parlé au président dites lui
que c'est important
bonjour chers amis désolé de vous
déranger moins cher président mais pour
mon bridge du 27 je peux compter sur
vous et sur jane fostin oui bien entendu
hélas non parce que voilà ce qui se
passe j'ai un ami qui départ de rome à
l'improviste
oui c'est un excellent bridgeurs mais je
ne voudrais pas que nous soyons
surnombre vous savez ce que c'est ça
désorganise une soirée ce sans problème
nous venons sa présence est inutile tout
à fait inutile bon je reprends
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous ne
pouvons tolérer une négligence de nature
à compromettre un programme aussi
important
[Musique]
parce qu'un ami a hélas c'est pourquoi
un paquet pour lui bon bah voilà
joe un paquet pour toi une boîte à
chaussures
[Musique]
cette conscience
oh
keller avait beau marguerite 6 à 25
lâcher
nous avions convoqué aux 10 à 18 heures
oui monsieur téléphoner avait les pieds
qu'il arrête et qu'elle me l'amène
immédiatement vous sortez cependant
prête parce que on va regretter avec moi
même pour la police j'ai pas le droit au
nom de dieu
et oui merci merci
je vous le répète francis vous perdez
votre temps dans cette aventure
je me permets je vous en russie rien à
cacher je vous le répète consiste vous
perdez votre temps vous pourriez faire
une vraie carrière à la cour de
cassation par exemple au lieu de vous
font rire dans cet appartement d'après
vous déjà si quoi celui-ci lee vous
savez lire quoi au fait ça veut dire
service interministériel de liaison et
d'information oui j'entends bien mais
quel est le but de cette institution
fonds but s'attaquer aux inattaquable
vous voulez dire mes amis les amis de
vos amis ne sont pas systématiquement
mes amis mais pourquoi cette hostilité
parce que je suis un serviteur de l'état
eh bien j'espère que vos activités à la
tête du comité de salut public ne vous
empêcheront pas de venir dimanche à
freiner tirer le faisant avec moi avec
le plus grand plaisir merci aux deux
guerres l'équipe musée dans ton du film
meurtrier que dirait albert albert
schweitzer il serait bien fâché si tu
avais tué sept fournir cette malheureuse
pet a certainement une famille à sa
charge
yatuu passé seulement enfin lit mes
fesses ou alors que va redire ça il ya
des responsabilités
serais-tu assez cruel pour immoler sa
peau
alors monsieur le juge a dit bonjour à
villequier oui excusez moi de vous
déranger sita j'essaye de vous joindre à
manger pas réussi voilà quand je suis
arrivé rue pierre demoures o dia était
mort sur un assassinat mais une balle en
plein front
tiré à bout portant bien monsieur jamais
et bien je suis navré mon père mais je
crains d'être dimanche dans
l'impossibilité de me joindre à vous ce
n'est pas de gaieté attention tu
viendras nom francis nous serons
vendredi soir en sologne vont
certainement robust l'hiver oui mais lui
n'étaient pas mariés c'est à rome que
vous avez connu depuis audiard oui j'en
ai souvent à peu près tous les deux mois
sur la vigne à un très bon client
alfredo donne à qui
qu'est ce qui les faisait odiah savez il
ne parlait pas beaucoup
un soir il m'a déclaré qu'il était agent
secret qui avait été accusée à tort de
comme ça contre
je ne sais pas la sûreté intérieure de
l'état ou quelque chose comme ça
et qu'il était sur la touche en exil
depuis près de cinq ans
il y avait de l'argent ça pas beaucoup
[Musique]
est ce pas beaucoup par quels moyens il
m'avait expliqué que c'étaient des amis
politiques qu'elles aidaient en
attendant des jours meilleurs
[Musique]
climat les si je vous pose cette
question mais
à rome entre le riot games une aventure
oui période
oui tiens
oui vous l'aimez poser dès son retour à
paris
vous étiez d'accord oui
[Musique]
et andré lavigne était au courant de ses
projets pourquoi
[Musique]
parce que depuis deux ans j'ai été la
maîtresse d'andré la ville
[Musique]
qui
vous l'aimiez peut-être un peu au début
et puis je me suis laissé aller par
facilité moi je comprends
coût
reprenons andré lavigne connaissez louis
odiah c'est sûr ils étaient même très
amis et si s'est passé hier
[Musique]
bien andré et moi nous sommes allés
attendre l'omi à orly ça me gênait un
peu ne voulais pas qu andré se rendre
compte de quoi que ce soit et puis ça
s'est très bien passé nous sommes allés
directement repères de moore pour fêter
le retour de louis il était tellement
heureux tous les trois
oui mais c'est pas un peu délicat si de
toute façon j'avais l'intention dans les
jours suivants d'avoir une explication
sérieuse avec andré
lavigne était au courant de votre
aventure avec louis absolument pas et
louis savez que vous étiez la maîtresse
de tendre la vie j'avais dit que tout
était terminé entre andré et moi il m'a
décrue d'ailleurs dans une certaine
mesure c'est est prêt
cette partie à quelle heure il devait
être trois heures j'avais rendez vous au
bureau à 3h30 j'étais à leur ouïe et
l'aurait cru que ces modes de vous poser
à nouveau cette question mais soit une
question délicate
il ya rue pierre demoures entre 14h et
15h
louis et vous oui monsieur le
commissaire à cette heure là ça n'arrive
peut-être pas aux gens de la police mais
ça arrive aux gens normaux
si ça nous aurait aussi que fois
ils sont arrivés tous les droits vers
12h45 bien autre question l'appartement
est resté longtemps inoccupé 50 25 ans
il faut le dire vite sur la vigne
mademoiselle jaggi mener d'autres fois
par semaine parfois même il reste à la
nuit ont marqué je vous dis ça contre
nous pour les soignants non républicain
je vous dirai pas les miens non plus un
bond en arrière
monsieur la vigne et mad men et jacky
sans particulaire monsieur la vigne est
parti à peu près quand vous êtes arrivé
avant ou après moi sincèrement je sais
pas et mademoiselle jacky 90
comment pouvez-vous dire autant de
précision mais ma fille tiaret venait
d'arriver
elle quitte l'école à 4 heures et qu'on
est à cinq minutes j'étais en train de
préparer son chocolat quand j'ai vu
sortir mademoiselle jacquier mais à part
ça pas d'aller venu je suis régalé a
reçu aucune visite à la passe il
possible que je réfléchisse chez vous
j'ai vu un drôle de type vers 15h45 qui
est monté hier de dire le connaissiez
non alors comment savez-vous qu'il
allait chez odien mal cause de
l'ascenseur sûr en tant qu'image peux
vous dire les tâches auxquelles il
s'arrête puis il a filé l'air plutôt
pressés dans un break 504 et julia vous
auriez dû être figure non non pas de
problème tout va bien c'est réglé vous
avez vu dans le journal ce contretemps
appartient au passé
mais le sheikh andré lavigne j'attends
toujours la cape d'hermine
vous pouvez compter sur ma chère madame
[Applaudissements]
louis était pas mal comme un fils était
très ami avec son père à sa mort j'ai
voulu lui évite le pire
louis était elle un noceur mythomane
faible
alors il a fait des bêtises et a même
trempé dans les affaires louches et dû
quitter la france pour se soustraire à
la justice
il venait d'être mis astier alors j'ai
voulu lui donner une nouvelle chance
testament n'a pas voulu ainsi la foule
hier en fin de matinée vous êtes allé
chercher à orly oui seul nom j'étais
avec une de mes collaboratrices moselle
l'homo elle connaissait déjà le
mouloudia
oui mademoiselle lhomond dirige mon
service d'exportation elle se rend
souvent à l'étranger quand ils sont
rencontrés à rome
pardonnez mon indiscrétions n'y avait
rien entre louis idiart à plaisanter et
ma vous ne l'aviez jamais employer notre
service a jamais cédé à un livre en
souvenir de son père mais si j'avais su
que ça devait se terminer de cette façon
là je vous remercie de cette
conversation et plus qu'à prendre un
congé pour accompagner ce commissaire
eh bien
voilà toutes les données du problème une
seule chose est certaine c'est que jacky
lhomond a menti jérôme voilà chaque kilo
mon et prétend avoir quitté
l'appartement à 15 heures or le
concierge est formelle elle est partie à
16h10 quelle est leur du décès
l'heure du décès d'odiah entre 15h30 et
16h d'après le médecin légiste donc elle
a vu la seule ça or elle se tait alors
soit parce que là quelque chose derrière
la tête soit parce qu'elle a peur un peu
de poids mais audi a été envoyée ou
alors c'est peut-être un règlement de
compte dans ce cas on passe à faire à la
criminelle et et la vigne pouvait
repasser la photo de la ville jérôme
double non la vigne autour du cou
d'abord il est parti à 14h ensuite il
n'était pas au courant de la liaison ou
dit jacky et puis je n'ai rien trouvé
son sujet tous les renseignements
bancaires personnelles et
professionnelles sont excellents son
affaire marche très bien non et pas dans
le coup je ne suis pas du tout votre
avis
lavigne ne me plaît pas à quoi comme ça
au pif
moi je veux bien continuer à faire des
photos sur toutes les enquêtes m'enfin
notre côté mungo mairie spéculant sur le
visage de romell ça nous mais nous et
qui regardez cette photo là bas ces deux
hommes c'est parce qu'ils aient fischer
il se parle silencieusement mais ils se
parlent et se disent tu sais que je sais
que si tu fais ce calcul c'est un tel
but dont tu vas faire autrement mais
comme tu te dis qu'en faisant autrement
je serais que tu veux me faire croire le
contraire de ce que tu prévois qu'il va
donc agir comme si tu n'allais pas le
faire comme tu sais que je sais que tu
sais tu veux me suivez mais c'est ça
voilà la conception fondamentale des
luttes moderne
c'est l'analyse regardez bien la vie en
train de vous serrer la mallet est en
train de se dire il qu'ils aient jeté eu
il est dans le coup j'en suis sûre non
non non non non
pure spéculation de joueurs une seule
chose est certaine c'est que le crime a
été fait par un professionnel jean namia
loft à vérifier en plus si un témoin qui
c'était très important non maintiens ce
que je dis je suis sûr que j'ai raison
de penser que quand je pense je pense
que j'ai raison me suivait et bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant qu'il disparaisse mon copain a
expliqué lacombe il des fourrures on a
trouvé la déchirer une page de journal
il en a mis un bout dans la poche du
vison allongé l'autre il me l'a donnée
le louvre est là oui oui vous avez bien
sûr vous n'avez qu'à venir voir à bercy
[Musique]
regardez dans quel état il est membre
est de 504 alors on me prenait vraiment
pour un con
monsieur le juge mon ambassadeur
transmettre à votre demande enquête à
notre goût je vous remercie fallait
absolument que je vous met au courant il
ya un os un gros à petit le mans qui
était chez rhodia au moment où il a eu
son malheur a causé c'est cette vieille
[ __ ] de villequier qui me l'a appris
sans s'en rendre compte
je pense qu'il faut que je la fasse
taire mais ça occasionnera des frais
vous avez été engagées et payées pour un
travail déterminé donc il ne devrait y
avoir aucune bavure c'est votre problème
contactez rampe est en train de nous
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
[Musique]
à
je dois je vous conduire madame à la
maison ritter
[Musique]
et alors ce modèle-là irréversible
vous rentrez les poches bien sûr et je
crois que c'est un bon moment et le
problème de la pluie problème tous nos
modèles sont imperméabilisées bon
j'arrive je m'excuse monsieur beaulieu
et savait que jacky remercie gilles
henry au point de vue livraison bonjour
en bray vous êtes seul on m'a appris que
ces messieurs
oui et ce qui je veux parler ces
messieurs s'intéresse d'un peu trop près
mes affaires plus que sur une heure à
peine j'étais informé par un ami chargé
de mission au ministère
ils ont déclenché une enquête vous
arrêtez tout on peut toujours le faire
bloquer suite à la réflexion vous avez
raison photo il faut que les choses se
déroulent de façon invraisemblable
ben vous ne bougez pas où et quand votre
camion passe la frontière
ok je pourrais la ferme
thual fois non
préserver une place dans n'importe quel
avion pour nice ce soir au nom de
mademoiselle lhomond et vous lui
demander de venir ici immédiatement
c'est par l'avion pour nice ce soir
tu donnes une voiture tu vas tu me tues
contacter le camion de la ti qui passera
la frontière entre 85 heures du matin
qu'il continue sa livraison officielle
sur amsterdam et qu'en aucun cas ils ne
s'arrêteront flanc
va pas ça va 100 ça me fera du bien à
elle n'a pas une place de disponible sur
aucune ligne cause du week-end j'ai tout
juste réussi à avoir une option sur le
vol de sa veine à 23h15 annulé tout et
pourquoi 23h15 ça ira très bien même si
on sait pas une certitude je peux pas
prendre de risque et 5 heures tu es
largement le temps dans la route du
saute dans sa voiture et tu descends sur
la côte à l'est vers
[Musique]
[Rires]
à
non
[Musique]
il va donc y avoir un camion de la
truite qui va faire rome paris amsterdam
dès qu'ils entrent en france vous leur
père et je vous le suivez surtout vous
n'intervenez pas mais si le camion
s'arrête chez la ville
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui et moi oui salut alors bon bon vous
n'intervenez sous aucun prétexte
non non et puis faut pas le filet en
permanence parce que je peux vous soyez
repéré à aucun pays bas et les problèmes
voyez encore rien un crime cette menace
de faire ça sent le roussi mme merkel
auront pensé qu'il serait à lyon bon
quoi attends je mets la banaliser le
prendre en charge ou au péage de
villefranche entre 1h et 2h ont révélé
près de bien d'accord mais vous me
téléphonait toutes les demi-heures pas
simple je bouge pas de chez moi
ouais d'accord d'accord la corde bon
d'autre part aux smart
oui je sais de ton père szirokko dans le
tiercé c'est bon pas là le donne à mon
petit jeu c'est pas bon c'est dimanche
le 7 août je voulais te montrer les
contrats prévoient ensemble c'est
vraiment le moment
ben oui c'est jamais le moment avec toi
écoute tu m'écoutes ou pas mais non tu
écris ces écoutes
ah bon tu peux faire deux choses en même
temps alors voilà
le mois dernier j'ai fait 5 530 francs
d'économies ce bain comme ans seulement
est alors voilà que les jeux pour ce
mois ci il ya la traite de la machine à
laver ça fait 350 francs
et puis il faut absolument qu'on
remplace les deux lits des petits alors
je voulais te demander la pièce que tu
pense qu'on peut mettre ce que l'on peut
mettre d'argent va pour rembourser lit
je porte mon fou a eu tout faux
non mais attendez bien boire pour notre
nouveau marché on est en retard
j'essaie mais j'ai perdu du temps avec
les bavures que l'on connaissait parce
que j'étais fort heureusement tout est
en ordre mais bon maintenant les
prévisions de trésorerie
il vous faut combien pour l'ensemble de
nos affaires électroniques qu'il faudra
compter 20 millions
un carton rassurer de 40 sur trois mots
les parfums 30 mai pour 60 même des
lecteurs à faire la plus intéressante si
vous avez toujours d'accord
c'est la fin 4 il vous faut combien 25
sans aucun risque mais sur 60 jours
c'est entendu
nous en avons terminé
pardonnez j'ai déjeuné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme moi je vais téléphoner monsieur la
cuisine mais on verra ça plus tard pour
la ligne allait vraiment une pièce je
vous prie
[Musique]
on
le visons pas longer mois
et voilà
[Musique]
voilà
à la vie mais je suis en plein bridge je
me savais ce que ces mots là je vous
présente mon ami le commissaire bull qui
est madame bridgeurs
en quelque sorte oui il manie
admirablement le squeeze je vois
et de quoi voulez-vous que je ne des
fausses
avec na mia odiah et la vigne ça fait
déjà trois de chute et vous n'avez plus
de tout si j'ai même las
et vous le savez très bien
je paie pour voir le poker maintenant
combien
votre liberté ce n'est pas à vous que je
vise
et si je refuse si vous refusez je vous
embarque immédiatement en garde à vue je
vous assure que je ne sois pas pour
jouer à la belote
j'ai votre parole de gentilhomme
oui
lavigne paris fourrure raynaud colmar
roulements à billes grâce gagny grenoble
électronique dumont bordeaux les vins
senti au roi les parfums il me manque
une carte et c'est la meilleure
robert de punta
alors qu'est-ce qu'il administre hilali
merde ça veut dire stop
non ça ne veut pas dire stop ça veut
dire allez-y mais doucement
alors aux français oui deux pentes am
cochera demain soir en prison ou bien
et vous lui ferez porter le monde et du
caviar
pourquoi vous dites ça parce que vos
ronds de jambes avec les deux veuille ou
et deux ponts tam j'avoue que je ne
comprends pas très bien
est ce que vous comprenez le juge eu
deux charrettes
j'ai un peu de mal que ça m'arrive
alors faites un effort
en d'autres temps monsieur par égard aux
noms que vous portez je vous aurais
tendu et revolver et je vous aurais
laissé seul dans votre bureau
mes fonctions mais n'interdisent est
aussi le sentiment que rien excuses ce
que vous avez fait je sais que l'argent
et les relations politiques permettent
beaucoup de choses mais pas tous je vais
vous envoyer en prison
les écrire mademoiselle note pour le
vice-président moins cher ami atteint
par la maladie
je remets entre vos mains ma démission
de président de notre société
je vous prie de réunir d'urgence le
conseil d'administration sincèrement à
votre repaire de pantalon
on ne tape et ce à tous je suis prêt à
vous suivre
moi si
[Musique]
j'espère monsieur juge que vous me
permettrez de quitter cette maison dans
ma voiture personnelle
je vous en voulez
merci
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que ce soit en parle j'ai encore à
tâtons et l'infini j'ai topé jo ils en
auront établi ce pétard
la jolie passe à un tout c'est un beau
robbie à vado à paris chez un fumeur et
contractants non plus qu'il dit d'aller
tout le monde est sonné vignac prendra
toutefois trop naïve et les périodes au
père noël à la fabrica les compagnies
lacc élargir nos moyens un sac à mal les
cercles de l'enfer au but à 3
ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui se passe en occident
où
nous
[Musique]
vous
et
[Applaudissements]
ah oui quoi
ma femme ma femme vient d'être révisé
pour la sous préfecture alors non ici
viviani a eu un accident
sa voiture a brûlé démarra
tout ce qu'on a dit n'avoir plus de
raison d'être accordé moins d'une minute
ça tu ranges
ça tranche je viens d'appeler mes
associés nous sommes d'accord nous avons
une proposition à vous faire nous
faisons toujours la faire mais j'y mets
deux conditions premièrement je veux 51%
des actions c'est normal l'afer est
beaucoup plus risqué maintenant il
suffira de rajouter aux contrats 2% et
de les donner un homme de paille
quelconque il n'est pas question bien
sûr que je devienne majorité en ont
deuxièmement c'est vous qui devenait le
pdg des tissages d'artigny vous n'aurez
qu'à nommer gaubert président d'honneur
n'acceptera jamais on sent viviani et
son procédé
il ne lui reste plus beaucoup
d'arguments à présent vous êtes la seule
chance de lusine sainte arrange aussi je
veux être tout à fait franc je risque le
paquet sur vous mais sur vous seuls à
vous de donner la preuve de vos
capacités et vous en avais je le sais si
vous ne réussissez pas bon je me serais
trompé mais il n'aurait rien perdu je
suis sûre que vous réussirez
[Musique]
un autre il est assez piquant et comme
ça le surplus je vais remettre du
charbon federer
[Musique]
elles mêmes et 8 pastis double d'abord
vous allez me parler sur un autre gd oui
pastis double cg33 du service
vous êtes assez sous comme ça à l'est du
mans oui
[Musique]
ouais
dis merde vient tout ça
de probables de masse et fait chier à
lucile avec ton service d'ordre
je veux pas faire la police partout
n'ont visité le maquereau de la patronne
vers d'autres moi je suis un client
[Musique]
photo cr-f
m
qu'est ce qu'on fait camarades en votre
nom à tous
je tiens à adresser quelques mots à
maria ruiz pour lui exprimer notre
solidarité avec elle
nous pleurons son fils notre camarade
antonio ruiz odieusement 1 battu par
bernard qui n'a pas hésité à porter dans
la rue
la répression dont il a la charge
à nos yeux il légal au tissage d'arte
signé et tout ça c'est la faute à ces
[ __ ] de gaubert dit camarade camarade
nous n'avons pas à manifester autour
d'un cercueil seulement à dire 1 maria
rhuys que nous sommes avec elle dans le
combat pour la justice la dignité et le
droit au travail
[Applaudissements]
ils ont libéré berna
ils ont libéré bernard bernard en finale
et les malaises des entreprises de
thyssen industries dont la productivité
est encore importante
mais dans la production traditionnelle
et maintenant concurrencer par les
techniques nouvelles
c'est sans doute ce qui explique la mort
d'antonio ruiz ce drame industriels
cette mort de ce jeune chômeur livré
lui-même abattu d'un coup de fusil par
le chef du service de surveillance des
tissages d'artigny dans le café tenu par
sa femme
charles bernard est maintenant en
liberté provisoire mais cette décision
du juge raymond et différemment
appréciées récitation sociale qui
couvrait depuis plusieurs mois a pris
brusquement un tour plus aiguë
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
il parle d'implanter une usine de
tracteurs mais nous nous on n'est pas
des mécaniciens on est des spécialistes
de textiles de qualité enfin il paraît
qu'il n'y en ait pas est ce que tu as
dis moi non plus et puis c'est comme si
le sort s'acharnait voulez parler du
lamentable accident qui a coûté la vie
au jeune louise sinon c'est à créer ou
et monsieur robert vous êtes à la tête
des tissages darty ni quelle est votre
position
on a beaucoup de voir si les choses
bernard a tué c'est vrai mais en état de
légitime défense c'est pourquoi le juge
l'a remis en liberté rien de tout cela
ne justifie l'occupation de l'usiné
pourtant il était en état de légitime
défense légitime défense
vous appelez c'est de la légitime
défense ou croyez-vous qu'il était
obligé de thé bien sûr ruiz avait bu il
avait une bouteille à la main mais
bernard sait se battre c'est son métier
alors avec l'aide d'une ou deux
personnes n'oubliez pas que le bistrot
était plein il aurait pu facilement
maîtrisé tonio non non non non non c'est
un crime alors la liberté pour un
assassin d'un chômeur qui plus est
cependant justice de classe
tu as vraiment envie de me battre
oui
tu as déjà entendu parler de freud non
wenner
qui tu préfères spassky au fischer
spassky
pourquoi
parce que je joue pas pour du pognon
robespierre quoi rien joue
donc c'est pourquoi je vous en prie le
nom je sais bien vous suivez les
directives du ministre mais moi aussi je
fais mon possible croyez moi pardon oui
mais je vais voir si je voulais passer
le préfet pour vous je n'ai rien à lui
dire ou plutôt si qui lui que je
m'emmerde lui le gouvernement sa
république pourrie halloween se coiffer
non
dans le président gaubert est au comble
de l'émotion et non c'est pas possible
maintenant
non mais bien sûr on va dans la mesure
du possible
non non d'un goûter jeux je crois que
musique joue un peu dans quelques
minutes
très bien mais oui merci monsieur projet
clea ce même si le résultat de votre
entêtement ne peut arriver que les
usines par la police et après ça vous
êtes tous surpris d'avoir des
manifestants brûlent tout ce que ça
comporte de violence et de haine
je suis maître chez moi ma vivant
touchera jamais à mon bien et c'est par
la force que vous entendez de préserver
peut-être ce n'est sûrement pas
l'abandonnant attoumane hivernaux ne
mettez pas dans des états pareils ce
n'est pas bon pour votre coeur toilettes
john henry j'ai hérité de maman 33% de
la sphère j'ai donc le droit de donner
mon avis pour 33% et d'être tour 33%
dans la décision
[Applaudissements]
la raison
la décision est prise mon grand-père
agréé cette entreprise de ses mains mon
père l'a fait grandir et moi j'ai 40 ans
je la soutiens à bout de bras et je la
défends les défendre contre les grèves
de 36 ou l'été fondue contre les
allemands avaient défendu contre les
banques et je la défendrai contre vernon
nous traversons parce qu'ils fissent il
c'est vrai mais c'est pas la première
fois alors mes ouvriers n'ont qu'à faire
comme moi se battre faire face se serrer
la ceinture ou aller se faire [ __ ]
après tout cire le banc gaubert serait
pas d'ouvriers la rue s'appelle gaubert
la région s'appelle gaubert elle ne
s'appellera jamais chienlit ont peur
écoutez moi dans quelques minutes il
sera trop tard les forces de police
interviendront il y aura des blessés
peut-être des morts et on aura tout
perdu
et si on veut pas tout perdre et qu'une
solution fait rentrer vers londres oui
absolument environ c'est de l'argent
beaucoup d'argent et l'argent c'est télé
machine telle expansion
le rendement et le rendement c'est la
rentabilité une plein emploi pour nous
tous les ouvriers
sinon vous connaissez le processus elle
est en iront dans la licenciée de sang
si ça continue dans deux mois c'est 500
kilowatts dehors nuit n'en mourront pas
l'étaler paye à ne rien faire 80 % de
salaire à la retraite à 60 ans journée
est-ce que je suis à la retraite moi non
je travaille et je travaillerai jusqu'à
ma mort douce tu penses à la mienne un
mois je pense à celles de ma maison
précisément elle arrive à grands pas
d'ailleurs vous n'êtes pas le seul
responsable de l'époque qui veut ça
elle est condamnée à la croissance la
croissance et les banquiers contre les
banques on a aucune chance pour répète
notre seule chance et vernon recueil
d'accord c'est à dos d'homme très dur
seulement c'est un financier indépendant
d'accord il prend la majorité seulement
il nous laisse la responsabilité ça
c'est inespéré il n'espérait abandonné
un patrimoine net en effet il espérait
alors n'acceptez pas continuer à vous
battre tout seul autre navire prend
l'eau de toutes parts ou d'être seul
maître après dieu à bord vous voudrez
avec lui entêté et immobile car
l'échéance est là monsieur président
inéluctable vous la verrez mourir votre
entreprise
mais rassurez vous vous pourrez
continuer à la contempler une fois morte
parce que vos équipements vos machines
toussaint qui datent de poincaré
on pourra en faire un musée
[Applaudissements]
bande
je vais le signer ton torchon
[Applaudissements]
ça
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
en effet non
le tout pour en discuter avec vous je
vous avais beau représentant les
conditions de reprise du travail une
bonne négociation tant que ce sens
l'autre bernard borrel à dire à la tri
qui a laissé moins de deux minutes
charles bernard de fait plus partie du
personnel des tisanes martinique aubert
et compagnie voilà alors dans ces
conditions on peut discuter
vous êtes d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais fait demander si vous connaissez
oui jacques vernaud le financier je vous
vois venir quelqu'un que vous arrivez
l'abattre depuis longtemps mais sans
succès si vous n'êtes pas m'abandonner
une piste et du nouveau oui vernon vient
d'acheter en sous-main les tissages
d'artigny au vieux gaubert sortie ni
étonné samedi quelque chose c'est pas
loin de chez moi ça je vis sur la tv ou
si la houle mais c'est la manière
illégale dans cette affaire apparemment
non feint pas pour l'instant mais j'ai
la certitude que vernon appartient à un
groupe dont la spécialité est la
fabrication de trancault d'ilan palier
des naturalistes
pas tout à fait
cette nuance que ce ne sont pas des
animaux qu'ils trafiquent mais des
usines est absurde je te 18 gym pour les
voies moyen est pas absurde c'est même
très bénéficiaires en s'y prenant bien
il est tout aussi rentable de ne pas
faire tourner une entreprise que de la
faire vivre
ah j'ai pas dû bien suivre à l'école
parce que la gestion est assez difficile
mais le principe est enfantin d'une
entreprise qu'on maintient
officiellement au bord de l'asphyxié
on peut tirer trois avantages
premièrement al avantage fiscal
l'entreprise étant déficitaire ne paie
pas d'impôts deuxièmement dissimulation
de bénéfices les bénéfices venant
d'autres entreprises est réinvesti dans
celle ci soit disant à perte
troisièmement une subvention
quand l'entreprise exerce son activité
dans une région où la situation sociale
appelle le soutien de l'état comme c'est
le cas
effectivement j'ai pas dû bien suivre à
l'école
fait j'avais très difficile de prouver
la fraude c'est assez difficile en effet
mais on a une petite chance parce que
j'ai eu vent d'une affaire depuis le
départ alors nous allons suivre et
essayer de démonter le mécanisme que
vernon est en train de mettre en place
délicat et dangereux
oui
on va demander l'appui du ministre c'est
d'avoir du val d'yerres je vous
tiendrais mais j'y mets une condition
vous allez être appelée bien entendu
enquêter a requis ni avec l'héritier
alors il ya de bonnes situations
délicates et une affaire judiciaire en
cours
ne vous en mêlez sous aucun prétexte
c'est le juge vraiment qui en a la
responsabilité
il prendrait très mal une intervention
de votre part ils auraient raison je
vois déjà que combien votre présence
chatouillé sa susceptibilité
je vais d'ailleurs les faire parvenir
une note par le terme des souks
puis je vous demander monsieur le
ministre de ne pas lui dévoiler le but
réel de ma visite
je ne voudrais pas que vernon suite
alerté je vous remercie
[Musique]
ah c'est un spectacle dont je suis
malheureusement privé classe mario vous
remercie de votre visite monsieur albert
de nos villes je suis très sensible
c'est la moindre des choses monsieur il
entendu vous tiendrais au courant de vos
démarches ici bien entendu avant toute
chose
mon cher ami je tiens à vous préciser
que dans cette enquête la caractère
général artix ni ne représentent que des
retombées intéressantes certes mais d'un
aspect strictement régional
bien sûr en tout cas je ne vois pas en
quoi je puisse être utile mais on ne
sait jamais bon j'ai un collègue entre
flics on ne sait jamais évidemment entre
policiers bailleurs
[Musique]
alors je vous écoute
puisqu'il paraît que vous avez à me dire
et des plus grande importance pour moi
en f1 ça va me donner 5 bric c'est tout
pas plus mais pas moins c'est ce qu'il
faut qu'on me tire et se bat pour you
tube personne de benoît déjà que je suis
obligé les habitants de la ville epic
mal foutu à la porte
aller au tour mais pas que cinq vrai que
c'est un peu beaucoup pour la dignité
supplémentaire de licenciés c'est la
condition pour que je disparaisse
je me taise vos désirs
qui est pro viviani a été assassiné je
le sais j'y étais
marcion révèle vous allez plonger
[Musique]
m
mr
c'est moins 48 heures
je vais réfléchir
pas plus
je compte sur vous aussi mon on ne les
lâche pas d'une semelle ces parisiens va
pas être facile facile de travailler
avec ces progressions ils ont leurs
prérogatives
ils y tiennent je vous prie de ne pas
tenir rigueur à mon père de son absence
il faut le comprendre mais il a tort
tout à fait tort car précisément aussi
je vais en allemagne c'est pour lui pour
vous j'ai rendez vous avec helmut forte
ce un important fabricant de vêtements
de luxe gros importateur de tissus de
qualité et que j'ai intéressé à vos
productions
j'escompte à un gros un très gros
contrat même d'ailleurs si la sphère se
concrétise je vous tenez faudrait
sûrement mon cher ça étrange pour que
vous veniez me rejoindre à sarrebruck
quelque chose qui ne va pas
aussi si si si tout va très bien nous
pourrions passer au salon vendues
j'ai voulu parler parce que j'ai un
petit problème je voudrais vous demander
conseil
je vous écoute mon cher voilà vous
souvenez de pietro viviani oui enfin
l'homme la brique est mort sur la route
de paris
bon et bien nommé charles bernard qui
était mon chef de sécurité l usine
prétendent que ce n'était pas un
accident et que vivendi était associé à
d'autres tout révéler la politique du
personnel
tron ont été prononcées
tout risque sur probation
bavarde on accuse kojfer chargé sur le
travail sur l'usiné
ce serait très ennuyeux présent lui en
effet
[Musique]
fecamp
accor
[Musique]
à
oui on vient de la part des saints-anges
ouais vous avez le fric
[Applaudissements]
bayal compte pas tout ça c'est parfait
t'as plus qu'à nous faire a reçus alors
c'est juste un petit reçus comme quoi on
a bien vu le fric et puis quand c'est
pas casser afrique
[Musique]
voilà quelque chose mais on sait tous a
reçu de monsieur sainte range la somme
de 50 mille francs c'est tout voilà
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
et
à tort
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]
le semble
nous divise
ah voilà riche s'arrange français
d'accord expliquez-lui mon cher régler
ça c'est en exclusivité tout ce qui est
disponible soit environ 80% de ce que
produisent des tissages darty mais c'est
formidable
voilà vous n'avez plus qu'à signer le
contrat
g
je peux pas signer ça pas vous mâcher de
3 47 francs le mètre c'est à peine mon
prix de revient comment voulez-vous
faire en sorte ça tu ranges ne l'ont pas
jouer à cache cache à leurs cartes sur
table je ne mets pas d'argent dans les
tissages ni pour vos beaux yeux ni par
philanthropie et pour gagner vite et
beaucoup je refuse voilà qui
m'étonnerait quand ça je vous garantis
que personne ne me fera changer d'avis
vous voulez parier un objet de
méditation
vous pouvez en faire ce que vous voulez
vous pouvez même le détruire l'original
et dans mon corps
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
c'est
premièrement photos de l'oea et de vous
de la broutille me direz vous mais je
sais cartigny où l'on a des principes on
sera sensible à la broutille
deuxièmement les travaux de pietro
viviani découvert dans sa voiture au
moment de sa mort quand vous aviez
raison l'autre soir de me dire que ce
serait très ennuyeux pour vous si l'on
découvrait que pietro viviani a été
assassiné qu'on lui a volé ses papiers
événement dont la conséquence première a
été votre nomination comme pdg
troisièmement enfin beaucoup plus grave
un reçu signé de la main propre de
bernard à l'ordre de gérard sainte
arrange pour la somme de 5 millions de
francs anciens en échange de son silence
qu'il soit dit en passant est
aujourd'hui définitif
lorsque vous faites là ça ressemble
beaucoup à du chantage ça étrange
curieux chantage en vérité qui au lieu
de vous coûter de l'argent vous rapporte
au bas mot 300 millions de francs en
trois ans sans compter les confortables
émoluments de président
directeur-général des tissages d'artigny
oui monsieur le juge trois balles dans
le corps le revolver abandonné dans la
pièce bourrée d'empreintes ne l'être tav
témoin visuel elle vient de confirmer
son geste et de signer sa déclaration
mini aucun problème une affaire triste
et banale bien entendu monsieur le juge
mes respects préparer le dossier pour le
juge très bon
à monsieur le commissaire il faut que je
vous dise progrès de gatti son panier et
caudry via nita déposition est
enregistrée maintenant ça suffit
mais écoutez les deux l'affairé réglée
la cub et rieur je commence à en avoir
marre de devoir traîner au commissariat
alors je te préviens donc permis de
séjour expire dans huit jours mais si tu
continues à m'emmerder ta dernière
semaine tu la passante haut le plus
personne de me croire parce que je crois
[Musique]
mais avec tout ce que je sais vous
passez pas que ça donne envie de se
saouler
mais vous ne disiez que votre frère oui
il n'a pas pu se foutent en l'air sur la
c'est important
et puis quand on m'a appelé pour aller
on connaît tous le corps sur les lieux
[Musique]
deux complices la voiture avait brûlé
brûlé
oui seulement voilà quand il est parti
ce soir il avait ses papiers dans sa
serviette
elle était bien à sur le siège arrière
mais ce n'est pas du chanteur dedans
momentanée
deux centres alors la preuve
il ya plus c'est capital
[Musique]
et
et je vous n'avez pas 10 heures au
commissaire simon il m'écoute pas c'est
comme pour les deux gars qui sont passés
gb main basse à ça je tape avant la
mairie ce juste avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour un monsieur qui se noie dans
l'alcool il a un sens aigu de
l'observation pour prendre un set à zéro
c'est tout pas d'initiative fils qui
suit vous qui me dit ça oui c'est moi le
ministre a été formel et pour une fois
il avait raison la requête n'est pas
notre compétence enfin si elle mène une
erreur judiciaire ce serait regrettable
mais nous les pouvoirs rien d'ailleurs
qu'est ce qu'on fait on continue à jouer
les touristes henry d'ailleurs je vous
conseille d'aller visiter le très très
beau commissariat de police finit au
détour de la conversation vous aiguiller
adroitement votre collègue simon a de
mieux ça moi je vais voir gaubert et on
se retrouve ce soir au restaurant de
l'hôtel pour le menu touristique
[Musique]
il m'a pas du tout comment oui oui vous
avez bien fait de me prévenir j'arrive
de quel droit vous permettez vous de
venir ici sans mon autorisation on mais
j'avais l'intention de venir vous
trouver seulement je voulais vérifier
quelque chose avant vérifier oui non
seulement vous est incorrect mais en
plus vous voulez peut-être m'apprendre
mon métier or pour du tout alors pas du
tout c'est bon vous avez qu'il y avait
trois impacts de balle sur le tour de
berlin
évidemment que j'avais vu ses consignées
dans le rapport comprenez pour un
imbécile pas du tout simplement une
question
elles sont bien des même calibre ah vous
voulez marcher sur les plates-bandes et
bien vous l'aurais voulu
ne soyez pas étonnés de me trouver à ce
bureau ma faim depuis quelques temps mon
beau père devient plus à l'usiné ou
alors très rarement mais c'est donc à
moi qu'incombe la lourde tâche de
diriger l'entreprise alors que plus beau
et bien voilà vous pourriez mettre d'un
très bon conseil
je suis chargée d'enquêter sur les
possibilités de restructuration de
reconversion de financement
d'entreprises privées vous savez à quel
point d'autres régions ce problème est
délicat voire difficile alors vous vous
avez réussi
vous avez réussi à obtenir un
financement 9 et votre exemple pourrez
si vous le voulez bien mettre très très
très utile bien sûr lyon
eh bien j'ai commencé par
[Applaudissements]
ah oui oui oui bien sûr que oui c'est ma
femme alerte actionnaires dans
l'entreprise j'espère qu'il ne verrait
pas d'inconvénient à ce qu'elle se
joigne à nous amène au contraire c'est
un peu léger remis je vous présente
monsieur albert de neuville ménagement
et alors comme je vous le disais j'ai
trouvé la collaboration d'un groupe
parisien en fait c'est un important
groupe financier prisé et serait-il un
discret de vous demander des conditions
de son apport à vous inquiéter sur les
tissages d'artigny monsieur du tout
madame sur l'industrie régionale en
général vous êtes en mission officielle
non madame sur un plan ministériel est
cette petite enquête dans la région est
purement exploratoire alors voyez vous
monsieur vous ne nous en voudrez pas
mais je pense que l'on marie sera
d'accord avec moi serait trop délicat de
vous communiquer les informations
financières sur les tissages à non pour
des problèmes de gestion bien entendu
mais pour des raisons sociales la
moindre indiscrétion ici et c'est
l'agitation ne sommes pas à paris bien
sûr chamade admettre que tout va
j'avais pourtant dès qu'on dérange pas
ah oui parce que là c'est très différent
mais pas de préfet pour vous parce que
moi je remercie walder bonjour monsieur
le préfet d'être alité dans le même
temps un procès contre m mais monsieur
le préfet douce il doit être vous dire
que ta manette dans le ministre de
l'intérieur doit maintenant au bureau
je vous remercie mal informé monsieur le
préfet pour voir
[Musique]
les nouvelles vont vite je voulais dit
monsieur nous sommes basés à paris
[Musique]
les hommages chère madame monsieur bravo
olivier c'est un triomphe
vous qui êtes toujours réticents quand
il s'agit de prendre une initiative
là vous foncer comme un éléphant et
pourtant je vous avais prévenus qu'on
soit susceptible je veux bien mais quand
même il ya des limites
et puis permettez moi de vous dire
monsieur refuse que je suis légèrement
surpris de votre attitude qui n'est pas
seulement prudente qui est timoré
d'habitude d'habitude quand je fonce
sais que j'ai raison de fond c'est là je
n'ai pas foncer parce que j'avais la
conviction qu'il ne fallait pas foncer
en tout cas je crois que c'est notre
dernier menu touristique
ma vitre et à la cantine de la
sous-préfecture après s'il nous accepte
et voilà
désolé de faire aller chez vous mon cher
batteur maintenue on va vous parler
rapidement sinon c'est un peu trop
emballé ce matin et son ardeur a déteint
sur moi je voulais vous dire que tout
cela est oublié le préfet prévenu que
diam's à nos confrères autres mais on en
est même but
ne trouvez-vous pas qu'il faut mieux
collaborer plutôt que de perdre notre
temps comme m alors quel est l'élément
nouveau est bien après mon entrevue
orageuses avec le commissaire ville qui
est tout à l'heure on met votre attitude
était parfaitement justifiée mais non
mais si mais si
j'ai réfléchi à la question que vous
m'aviez posé sur le calibre des balles
et j'ai décidé tout de même de faire
procéder à un examen complet de blessure
que voulez vous ça ne nous avait pas
paru indispensable la sphère paraissait
clair des aveux écrits une confession un
revolver et alors le résultat définitif
ne sera connu que demain mais les
premières analyses semblent prouver que
vous aviez raison 1 2 bal seul de la
poitrine correspondent aux calibres du
revolver de maria lluis à 6 35
mais la troisième celle de la tête est à
7 65
autrement dit bernard aurait tué deux
fois et le témoignage de vie gagnées
donc à prendre en compte mais quelle
crédibilité devons nous accorder à cet
ivrogne que suggérer ou chancellerie
monsieur le juge cette affaire relève
entièrement de votre compétence et je
suis sûr que la décision que vous
prendrez sera la bonne
bien sûr mais puisque vous êtes ici vous
avez ne sont pas superflus
pour ma part si les affirmations du
laboratoire se confirme demain je
pencherais pour une reconstitution d'un
crime avec présence de viviani comme
témoin c'est exactement ce que j'aurais
fait mal
pour les 7 10 ans et que tu viens faire
ici toi [ __ ] de cette branche
je veux la voir sa peau voilà payer la
mort de mon frère
arrête de déconner angelo j'ai travaillé
sur un brevet et vous le savez bien les
gars je vous en avais parlé on a tué
pour qu'il laisse pas tu pas pour que ça
ne marche pas pour que ça tourne pas à
l'usiné
tu dis n'importe quoi angelo encore
bourré et tout ça c'est pour te venger
de sa tranche parce qu'ils te virer je
peux être bull et moi mais le
commissaire lui il est pas pourquoi je
serai convoqué demain
peter pan dans les constitutions
revoient leurs constitutions 0
oui mon pote pour le meurtre de cette
[ __ ] de bernard parce que moi j'étais
là et j'ai tout vu
oui et je vais causer
évidemment mais
qui téléphoniez vous saverne
pourquoi aux deux caisses que le cacher
ouais
rien gérard je vous en prie pour vous
avez raison c'est trop lourd pour moi
nous avons des amis à dîner ce soir vous
raconterez ça dans la voiture
[Applaudissements]
nous a mis dans une situation impossible
général depuis 50 ans et régions
s'appelle compères les tissages
d'artigny s'appelle compères les
gouvernants peut être manqué de
prévoyance
mais toujours ils ont su prendre leurs
responsabilités et bien aujourd'hui ne
nous reste plus qu'une solution de terre
tenir
non chers amis bonjour et bien si bien
qu'aujourd'hui estaca mitchell nous
n'avons pas ou ne sera pas donc si à mon
héritage d'un pénale et 7
vous êtes venus pour m'empêcher d'aller
à la reconstruction
1 au contraire visionner au contraire il
faut y aller
je veux surtout pas faire attendre ces
messieurs que la petite heure elle reste
avec nous tu vas être bien gentil du
bien poli avec eux et tu fermes ta
gueule tu fermes ta gueule sinon ta
fille ensuite qu'avez vous fait où avez
vous mis votre vélo moteur sûrement ici
puisque quand on a découvert le crime
votre engin était encore d'avoir la pop
[Musique]
eh bien nous allons faire appel au
principal témoin angelo viviani nous
vous écoutons
[Musique]
même un sérieux voyons viviani vous est
venue spontanément déclarer ce que vous
aviez vu fumer sa pipe
vous n'êtes pas gêné plusieurs fois en
ville et devant l'usiné pour déclaré
qu'avant l'arrivée de maria ruiz deux
hommes dans un break blanc avait stoppé
devant la villa je me souviens de rien
faites un effort viviani vous êtes le
seul témoin justement donné du tout
c'était pas là
comme je n'étais pas là
j'ai dû personnes
jeudi m'endormir la campagne chez paou
quelque part
[Musique]
ces liens
viviani
je vous rappelle que vous avez déposé
sous la foi du serment
c
je menti
je suis un pauvre type
[Musique]
vianney vous avez peur de quelque chose
aussi je pourrais faire peur l'inculpé
pour outrage à magistrat et vous
enfermez sur le champ je ne le ferai pas
je vais vous aider
[Musique]
suivent ont parlé de le faire
matin
notamment ils vont me tuer est ce que
vous dites oui mais là tu es rona ça
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je voudrais
je voudrais vous parler en confidence
[Musique]
bien dit on connaît tous on veut faire
moderne enfonce on débouche sur le
scandale n'y aura pas de scandale pas
pas monsieur van der de neuville a
promis à une condition madame vous vous
en souvenez je me souviens très bien ça
y est ainsi désormais les a lus par
surprise mais y'a mieux que ça vernon
oui absolument
les tueurs en parler alors je suis né où
chercher en fond sur paris on les
coïncidences on reste ici
mais pourquoi monsieur madame cintres en
jour parlé un peu tard il est vrai mais
ils ont parlé je tiendrai compte de leur
concours
ah bon devant moi ils ont téléphoné à le
chevet renom qui va arriver d'une minute
à l'autre
ils confirmeront devant lui leurs
déclarations et monsieur ça et bien que
signifie cet appel de détresse mon cher
sainte arrange je n'ai pas que votre
affaire sur les bras à moi c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire monsieur vernon
monsieur van der de neuville chef de
service interministériel de liaison et
d'information enchantée monsieur fernand
je vous prie de vous tenir à la
disposition de la justice
moti d'innombrables dissimulation de
bénéfices trafics financiers achats
frauduleux d'entreprises en difficulté
c'est tout non complicité d'assassinât
ridicule vous n'avez pas l'ombre d'une
preuve et d'ailleurs comment pourriez
vous en avoir il n'y a rien g j'ai tout
raconté aux juges valter évidemment ils
essaient de m'accuser pour se couvrir
lui mais contre lui il y a des preuves
j'ai un dossier je sais que vous aimez
beaucoup les dossiers mais moi aussi
j'ai un dossier contre vous qui suffit à
vous envoyer en cour d'assises
piètre viviani charles bernard et
maintenant renata vous êtes allé trop
loin vernon votre associé de munich
forte a été arrêté nos collègues
allemands sont intervenus nous avons
sakai et sa correspondance et les
numéros des comptes clandestins
ranger et ses aveux bien les plus graves
où tu as on parlait aussi
c'est fini vernon veuillez prévenir les
gendarmes
le commissaire simon le juge raymond le
sous préfet le préfet et je me chargerai
de prévenir le ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
non
b
[Musique]